how's it going everybody it's Warren and
with Marvel Studios now owning the
rights to use the x-men in the MCU it
was only a matter of time until he got
some official news at San Diego
comic-con in 2019 Kevin Feige name
dropped the Fantastic Four and mutants
confirming that Marvel Studios does in
fact have plans for them in the near
future now what exactly are Marvel
Studios has plans to introduce the x-men
into the MCU we're not too sure right
now however one thing is confirmed Kevin
Feige the president of Marvel Studios
wants to introduce Professor Xavier into
the MCU and this is confirmed by Sir
Patrick Stewart himself Sir Patrick
Stewart has recently revealed that he's
had many long long conversations about
the MCU the x-men and Charles Xavier
with Marvel Studios is President Kevin
Feige this is absolutely insane news I
don't think that anybody thought that
Marvel Studios would even attempt to try
and get back Patrick Stewart to play
Professor Xavier
but I'll break down everything that
Patrick Stewart said and what it means
for the future of the x-men in the MCU
in this video real quick I'm still doing
my xbox one and ps4 giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be subscribed
with notifications turned on at like the
video and leave a comment down below I'm
picking a winner when I hit 550 thousand
subscribers so as I just said Patrick
Stewart has revealed that he has
recently met with Marvel Studios as
President Kevin Feige about Professor
Xavier in the MCU he revealed this a few
days ago in an interview with Digital
Spy and in this interview he said I met
with Kevin Feige a couple of months ago
and we had long long conversations and
there have been moves and suggestions
which include Charles Xavier so here we
have literal confirmation that not only
does Marvel Studios want Professor
Xavier to be one of the main mutants
that is introduced into the MCU but they
also want Sir Patrick Stewart back to
play him as well now although this is
amazing news that Marvel Studios wants
this it doesn't seem likely to happen
unfortunately in this interview it seems
like he's pretty happy to step away from
the role he said in the interview here's
the problem if we had not made Logan
than yes I would probably be ready to
get into the wheelchair one more time
and be Charles Xavier but Logan changed
all that Patrick Stewart went on to talk
about the first time that he actually
watched Logan on-screen alongside a few
Jackman
about how the two of them broke down
together he said Hugh took my hand and
we held hands with the last seven or
eight minutes of the film because there
were so many things we were upset about
we were moved by the story we were moved
by one another we were moved by the
movie but we also both made the decision
that we were saying goodbye to our
characters as well in that sense it was
not just the deaths of those two men in
the franchise but it was also goodbye to
our part in them as well which is
completely and totally understandable
he's been playing Charles Xavier and
Hugh Jackman has been playing Wolverines
since the year 2000 and Logan was a very
very emotional movie and was a great way
to say goodbye to the characters now
does that mean that we're never going to
see Professor Xavier or Logan in the MCU
absolutely not in fact even though this
is sad news that Patrick Stewart will
not be reprising his role at Charles
Xavier it actually is good news because
it does confirm that Marvel Studios is
looking to get Professor X in the MCU
and it means that it's actually going to
be happening sooner than later
as Patrick Stewart said he met with
Marvel Studios months ago that means
Marvel Studios was looking to get him
into a project within the next few years
and this makes sense because there seems
to be a lot of evidence pointing towards
the fact that the x-men are probably
going to be introduced in phase 4 or
phase 5 we've even had reports that the
Illuminati are going to be introduced in
Doctor Strange in the multiverse of
madness and one of the main character in
the comics and one of the main
characters that has been reported by
Mikey Sutton to be in the Illuminati in
the MCU is Professor Charles Xavier this
could be the first sign that Marvel
Studios is planning the Illuminati to
make their debut in Doctor Strange and
the multiverse of madness but at the
very least it is confirmation that
Marvel Studios is looking to get
Professor X in the MCU some way or
another and it's also confirmation that
the x-men and mutants as Kevin Feige
said are not too far away from making
their MCU debut so of course it said
that Sir Patrick Stewart is not going to
be reprising his role as Professor
Xavier but let me know what you think
about this news and do you think that he
could change his mind if the story was
compelling enough and perhaps if Hugh
Jackman made a return as Wolverine as
well I'm sure that would influence him
so let me know what you think in the
comments down below let me know how
excited you are for the mutants to
finally enter at the Marvel Cinematic
Universe be sure to LIKE the video and
subscribe
notifications turned on to stay up to
date on everything relating to the MCU
and so you can enter my giveaway as
always thank you all so much for
watching woof woof